- Des photndndndndndndndndndndn.
- I think that one
is my favourite.
- Mais celle prise après
petits-enfants est sa préférée.
sososouvenirs déjà précieux,
devenus inestimables depuis
la mort de Byron Greff,
en Afghanistan.
Onze ans plus tard, sa mère est
toujours sous le choc et peine
été tué. Le caporal-chef
Byron Greff en était
à son deuxième séjour
en Afghanistan. Le parachutiste,
participait à la formation des
soldats afghans quanauauautobus
blindé de l'OTAN, à bord duquel
il se trouvait, a été la cible
qui devait être moins dangereuse
que sa premiè
Byronffffff choisit jeune
la carrière de militaire, après
un passage chez les cadets,,,,,,
où personne avant lui n'avaitfa.
"Mon fils voulait toujours
aider tout le monde, c'eavavavai
une carrière militaire",
raconte sa mère.
(vrombissement de l'hélicoptère)
la mission en Afghanistan
a été la plus longue opération
de combat de l'histoire
militaire canadienne.
et dernier soldat canadien mort
dans le pays.
Si sa mère pense évidemment
beaucoup à lui en portant
la Croa accepté le titre qu'elle
portera pendant un an
pour tous les autres morts
durant cette longue opération.
Pour Candy, le vide laissé par
la mort de son fils est immense,
mais les souvenirs, eux,
ne se limitent l l l l l l l l s
de chez elle, où repose Byron,
un véhicule blindé a été
installé à sa mémoire.
Un ban
sur le terrain de son ancienne
école secondaire.
"Les gens doivent être
conscients du sacrifice
de mon fils", cronononononononos
morts en devoir, les souvenirs
sont gardés précieusement.
En portant la Croix d'argent,
Candy les partager avec tous
les Canadiens.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Edmonto